we said something said something really
profound to you it's great to have both
my teas yes
kristaps porzingis welcome back nakorn
fly JJ Bryan with that soft touch that
ball just hangs around the rim and you
looking for singles right now even
against Harold constantly moving italo's
answer look it to a trailing porzingis
who shoots swamis luca gives it up to
porzingis and from center court from the
city court logo for fans to turn out and
say I'm a basketball fan not just if
these two teams I'm just a basketball
fan and here to talk
[Applause]
porzingis Griffin come emmaus coming out
to challenge if he goes right at Crumlin
then it will stare down Brunson throws
it up ahead cleave up to porzingis
a really difficult first 11 minutes and
59 seconds he spent stuck in the corner
crying self out of that problem and
porzingis along three five columns we go
into the back half of the fourth quarter
now
the unicorn drive it to the basket nor
get to the free-throw line in the
putback
where's Incas a1 where's the help was
the guy's jab and we sees bodies
concerned as you can't come off seth
Curry just amazing performance porzingis
wow there's the exclamation point from
Chris stops horse ingots
[Applause]
well again the threat of the three opens
up the drive
cork Moz a conscientious objector dives
out of the way and porzingis hammers one
over the top
talk to Malloy who's not the easiest guy
the world of thought to full court
situations multiple occasions this year
for half court launches and hits often
time
it's cool fifteen at six the road record
for Sega's turns it has an easy path to
go to the basket and throw it down about
the rim Rogers you called it hard though
one bounce
nobody healing bottom they say
and B leads to cool himself off with
early foul trouble and Ilan right does a
nice job defending as well here's the
grant home
in a good place right now laughs
recently averaging 14 rebounds in the
last 13 games that's nice
porzingis
goodness gracious I'm not gonna shoot it
I'm gonna go booyah is it granted well
that's nice to start off with a dunk
I'm good has this got dead lately Yanis
has 27 to the first half with a
preseason game looking to make it three
he has found a special place
unfortunately the only day that's going
to slow
at times is the only thing that can slow
down Luca dockage 55 is Google to be
searched with two shots around
this is to pull up
[Applause]
birdy would be jealous as Lucca finds
Dorian finney-smith that was perfect oh
my goodness
another time not an easy pass and
Thompson and Durant and all those guys
really nice pass Bernard a 40%
three-point shooter roll back to a
Rowley Dwight Powell that pass it looks
great
[Applause]
with a rim rockin dunk and an excellent
look at it from our incredible crew here
in Dallas is Don Cheech works the fail
banks it in
and I'll have a chance for 3 oz merits
at the end of the day you've given up 54
points with 9 minutes ago in a second
you got to find a way to shut your mouth
and begin to play with intensity rolling
in for KP since January 1st 10th to the
league 1.7 block
[Applause]
just look the defense off gleba finishes
it up the dockets two seconds left is
gonna doctors down
what a shot that's a good call miles he
set that one up - oh great look at it -
off the glass look at he use his right
hand it's a block that's 30 points in
the third quarter for Luca da judge with
that three-pointer opportunity for a
four-point play
[Music]
[Applause]